speaking of what's real or what's not
real is infinity real
who's infinity i mean the the you know
look the the
you can write down you know in wolfram
language there's a symbol infinity that
represents infinity and one over it is
zero
and you can say lots of things about it
if you want to ask the question
can i
make
an
infinite
um
can i sort of actualize infinity that's
this is a complicated question because
you can
certain kinds of infinities can be just
made symbolic and reasoned in terms of
to explicitly make infinity is a
different thing than to reason in terms
of infinity you know we can write down
transfinite numbers and we can do all
kinds of reasoning about transfinite
numbers that doesn't mean we can
explicitly in our universe
make a birthday cake that's a
trans-finite number so to speak i mean
we we can't um so the question of
actualization in the universe versus
symbolic representation is a little bit
of a tricky question
okay forget about us making infinity is
there a quality of the universe that's
infinite at all so for example infinite
space infinite computational speed
infinite memory storage
and and how can we inter even if there
was an infinite is there a way that we
could tell is there an experiment that
would let us know that infinity exists
in some way shape or form or is it
somehow irreducible it would look like
noise to us well i think we can wait for
an infinite time we'll know in the
infinite future we'll know if the
universe is infinite i mean i think that
before that
we can
um
you know
the
the question for example is space
uh
you know infinitely divisible that would
be a question we might ask
i
think
our models
look like they're going to make some
very specific predictions about what
happens in fast rotating black holes and
things like this
where they will kind of see through
there'll be a microscope that kind of
sees through
down to the actual fabric of space-time
and actually sees these discrete things
and were we to be able to use that
microscope and work to see
you know work to just keep seeing you
know finer and finer and finer detail
you know in other words we look through
a physical microscope and we're used to
seeing oh you know the biological
organism actually is made of cells oh
you know we look it's actually made of
molecules the molecules made our atoms
the atoms are made of whatever you know
and the question is space
right now we might think our microscope
for space
we just look and it keeps on looking the
same it's always indivisible you know
it's always it's always divisible and
the question is what we're saying in
this theory is no at some point you'll
see the atoms of space now you don't
really get to do that because you are
embedded your microscope is made of the
same atoms of space so you don't really
get to make a microscope that directly
sees that so you have to use more
indirect techniques to be able to kind
of sense the presence of these atoms of
space but you could certainly imagine
something where
uh you know you could you could predict
we don't know what scale precisely these
atoms of space occur but um where you're
kind of trying to um
um
uh you you're sort of making the
universe be in in such an extreme
condition that you kind of see through
to the structure of space it's very
similar if you're going through a fluid
you know a typical you know a car going
through air doesn't know air is made of
molecules it just knows there's a flow
of air a hypersonic plane missile or
something going through air absolutely
does know that air is made of molecules
of oxygen and nitrogen and so on because
at that speed you've kind of broken down
this continuum structure of space um
in that case a fluid of the air you've
broken down the continuum structure of
the air and you are sensitive to the
presence of individual molecules with
particular properties and so the
question is can we find extreme
situations in space time for example
where we're similarly sensitive to the
underlying structure of of space and you
know there's a decent chance that we may
have examples of that